people on twitter seem to think that you
might have a
girlfriend back at home damn that's
really that's a rumor
i definitely gained some clarity through
this process
all right i think i'm going to go with
sally
benny how are you feeling you came in
you shook things up and then you just
got out
you know um i actually think it's
hilarious you know i'm feeling good
though
i'm not too bothered about the quick
entrance and
just leaving like that um you know i
came in
and i knew what i wanted and i shot my
shot
and it didn't it didn't work out i
wanted to but it's all good
i'm still i'm still benny bivens you
know why did you have your eye on sally
like i
i know you've kind of talked about us on
the show but she was in one of the most
loyal couples from the beginning
although we saw as viewers from the
outside that we were a little
unsure about so how were you feeling
going in i really liked what i saw from
her
i really like her personality just the
the bubbliness this the loyalty
everything about her was just like
super my type so i was like you know
what i know she's in this situation
i know that you know she's really into
this guy and they've been spending a lot
of time together
but i'm just the type of guy i go for
what i want
i love sally i think she is like one of
the most delightful people on the show
that we've seen
but it's super frustrating to watch
the things that johnny has done to her
so the cards were kind of in front of
her do you think she made the right
choice during the recoupling do you
think that johnny
has is maybe your entrance kind of woke
him up a little bit
yeah i think if anything i kind of
set johnny straight in the way um i feel
like he definitely tightened up once i
got
there you know he was definitely trying
just to do everything
to get right with her because he was he
was worried
um he was nervous i think you know
she for a second she was going
to entertain you know getting to know me
a little bit more but i think the
pressure that he put on her
kind of like held her back so you know i
think
if anything i think i came in and i made
the relationship stronger and i'm not
mad about that if they're happy
i'm happy you know definitely definitely
is there anyone that you
wish that you got to know a little more
or spend more time with beyonce
honestly i wish i could have got to know
moyra
and kirsten a little bit better i should
have definitely you know kind of
followed up with them and
and see where they were at um but i
think i came in with the focus
on celi and that's probably where i made
my mistake
um i probably could have
gotten to know you know more maureen
kirsten a little bit better
and tried to pursue that yeah
just because again you know this going
in and
trying to sway sally away from johnny
was definitely
a long shot and i knew that but any
anyway i
like i don't want to look back and say i
have any regrets because i don't
right i'm in there and i did the right
thing i did what i wanted to do
and whatever happened happened yeah like
i think from a game perspective yes
going after maura might have been a
smarter move but i
kind of like you went in we're like i'm
i have my eye on celly that's who i'm
going for exactly
that's what i do you know i see
something and i want it i i go and
i go and shoot for it i go and do it so
let's clear up an
internet rumor that i'm probably telling
you about for the first time
people twitter seem to think that you
might have a
girlfriend back at home some internet
sleuths believe you have a girlfriend
okay any trouble you have a girlfriend
before you came into the villa
wow that's crazy so damn that's really
that's a rumor
yeah oh my god okay um you know i was
with somebody for a long time
and it was pretty recent the breakup and
that's why
i think people kind of assume that
i was with somebody but for the past
four months i have been single
okay yeah that's crazy though that's
that's wow
they will find it yeah definitely they
will pick it up so you and
you and the ex are done that is or you
might get back together
that's that's tough you know i think
coming here
i was definitely looking for distraction
yeah
because you know being so early in that
breakup i was definitely
looking to get away from my emotions and
i think i definitely did realize that
i'm hoping i can go back and i can make
something work out
um i'm just hoping
that hoping and praying honestly
because you know looking back like i
i i definitely
gained some clarity through this process
being in the villa maybe gave you some
clarity about
maybe wanting to be with this girl being
in that in that situation
seeing all the couples and everything it
kind of brought me back to
that feeling that i used to have and i
definitely
um realized like hey like i definitely
miss that
you know and i miss that with that one
girl and
i think the thing with sally it was like
a lot of her characteristics um were
similar
to my ex's characteristics and i think
that's what draw
like drew me towards her and um
you know like i said i just kind of
gained that clarity i
i feel like i'm hoping that i could
see i don't know i don't even know do
you know how she felt about you going on
love island
i'm not sure about that i'm clapping
with her okay
well get your girl if you could um
change anything about your experience is
there anything that you would change now
that it's all said and done
no i will admit not one thing i would
change i'm happy
that i came in and i i gained clarity
uh into different situations and i met
great people
and you know i i did what i had to do
i'm not mad about anything i'm actually
i have no regrets at all